foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
we are recording it's the show called
Lifeline we're recording it's this show
that we do it's called again Lifeline
nut shouldn't swear in the first minute
okay well bleep me out dude
honestly you censor me see if I care
me and my people will rise wow my people
who are your people my people are
you okay so I'll rise some of those
people over there is my hair okay today
let's see it's okay it's nice the hair's
been Pippin and yeah okay I like the hat
thank you Salem is it for the the
smoking it's the cigarettes that's how
you know it's not new
right because that's not a company
anymore right
um yeah it might uh still be a company
but you're not allowed to like make what
merchandise for cigarettes you can't
have any kind of advertising at all yeah
what's going on that's a a a real thing
oh God that's a real thing I didn't know
that when did that law pass oh we were
young remember Billboards you couldn't
you couldn't advertise
like Mr camo had to go no I don't
remember marble man wasn't allowed
around anymore I don't remember this
yeah dude you were kids yeah no I
remember the ads in like so you can't
advertise cigarettes no wow at first I
haven't seen it yet at first it was
within certain distances of schools
right right right right well that makes
sense and then it was just in general
because now it extends to like the
internet and everything yeah because you
don't see wow that's crazy huh the only
place you can is a place that actually
sells them you could put it in your
window that you sell how do you know
this
you always ask me how I know things I
know things by being a person in the
world like how is something that like
you can advertise cigarettes only in
places that sell cigarettes not
something you forget that's more what
I'm like retaining that info is crazy I
mean I just I've read about the law and
then I look deeper into the law and
learn those laws don't forget
I don't because I go if I read that I
would go huh and then I'd say
but I'd think about something else and
then I forget it here's the thing though
that's the thing I'm in I have a wider
interest than you do okay
trailing into the territory territory
it's why I'm smarter than you
know
no it's one of the reasons I'm smarter
than you because you're smart you just
don't apply your brain in the right way
I'm very smart and also I'm smarter than
you
no way yeah no way
no one who knows us would ever see
people that'll do it can you imagine the
kind of person that would be like oh
yeah Chris is smarter than Matt can you
even imagine what that person would be
like I'm pretty [ __ ] smart man even
dumb people know that I'm smarter than
you so it's being so we're treading into
dick territory
um sure you know sometimes you got to
tell it like it is you know no I'm very
smart and there's different kinds of
smarts okay so how about Street smarts
you have those yeah they're not more
than I do I think maybe
but we can't really measure that though
you know yeah that's true yeah yeah you
can't even measure really smartness when
it comes to knowing things either so
yeah but you can because people talk to
me they talk to you and they say oh Matt
smarter oh well it's December 18th we
got one week before Christmas what are
you gonna do you're gonna get Lifeline
merch what are you gonna do oh you know
what honestly you should have your
holiday shopping already done by the way
I'm wearing the don't push me
um merch here that uh I can get a
chrisley.com oh and I'm wearing a
lifetime
merchandise that you can get uh uh
Lifeline merch uh.com right merchandise
emergency
um and uh you if you got a question go
to watch lifeline.com and send in a
video for us or you can go to do
one-on-one advice sessions with Matt you
do both at Matt come on the show then
get down and dirty get deep in the weeds
with this Matt Dalia that's me deep in
the weeds down and dirty and the weeds
down and dirty that's how we do it in
the private sessions you should have
heard me earlier this week it was some
wild stuff yeah doing that with the
fingers was it was wild stuff okay okay
Wild
Wild
stuff that's
very weird and off-putting and when you
do that you've got to talk like that no
you don't you don't have to do that or
talk like that how about you do this you
talk like this okay
so
I will be in San Diego January 7th
chrisley.com uh Portland and Seattle
I'll be there later on in January and
Lakeland Daytona and Jacksonville San
Antonio Sugarland Texas New Orleans
Providence New York City Chicago Kansas
City Springfield Tulsa check out these
Austin Midland Texas Minneapolis
Columbus Cincinnati Ohio and Boise I
will be there get your tickets at
chrisley.com I'm also adding more uh out
of at a at a rate that is unbelievable
you wouldn't even believe the rate he's
adding but I'm adding more of those
shows so go to chrisley.com and check
out uh tickets for my tour don't push me
I'm wearing a shirt what's up what's up
my lifeline listeners what's up
um
yeah I do remember that as a matter of
fact I will tell you this much David
Sullivan's first we talk about David
Solomon law he's my friend who's really
fat he's been on the show big head you
know there's a Lifeline lives they've
seen his enormous head yeah and he's
really fat and he's short and he's
[ __ ] shits in his pants a lot and uh
he basically is uh a great actor okay
and he is and he does his first
acting role ever was I forget what show
it was on but his he had one line and it
was was that did you know that no I
didn't know yeah did he play fat guy who
smells that guy who smells vodka who
obviously smells is what it was called
even though it's on TV and everything
obviously smells who has an enormous
head yeah I dropped something hold up
and then when he walked in for uh the
audition he said uh they all they all
said oh you're perfect for this yeah
because don't even do the line yeah yeah
and he got the part so um anyway hit my
head it's all great oh great and I will
say this and it sounds defensive sounds
defensive but hurt so minimally and I'm
so happy about that I was worried you
know what's weird yeah I don't like you
that much but okay well you do right but
you know what I mean yeah but when you
potentially get hurt huh it's so sad for
me like I my heart breaks what the [ __ ]
bro I don't need that I don't know it's
not in service for a video I'm just
saying like I have an immense uh uh it's
like a mechanism Within Me biologically
it's just like automatic Brothers if I
see yeah if I see you in potential pain
or like one way like hitting my head
just like that I was like oh no what
yeah yeah
yeah wow I wonder what that's what I
made fun of you for it but you know I
needed to know you weren't actually hurt
first but even if I was hurt how bad
could that have possibly hurt it would
have been like ow oh [ __ ] okay it's over
you could have got a concussion not from
that Coulda no I said so
no dude it doesn't matter if you said so
you're wrong no no listen to me I said
so okay so I don't like you don't have
to I got it I'm fine you're good yeah
and you're gonna be cross-eyed and
falling asleep by the end of the episode
you're very uh you're very capable and I
don't feel bad when you almost hurt
yourself because I don't I know you're
very capable and I I'm secure in that
what is it about me that makes or was it
about you that makes it seem like I'm
not capable of dealing with pain
oh I have a hard time relinquishing
control and when I see something that uh
makes me feel any kind of negative
emotion that is out of my control it's a
ding ding ding reminder that I don't
control anything in this universe
everything's random nothing matters and
uh okay we're all gonna [ __ ] die so
deep in the same sad depressing [ __ ]
way alone
drooling [ __ ] absolutely having no
thoughts in our minds because they're
mush okay well that's if you dive all
damage but not if you die from a train
you're not alone and you crush interfere
with tons of people don't die and you
your last thought was really with it you
could be with it good good way to go
although that's not automatically not a
good way to go is just like just like
out of nowhere I don't like thinking
about it yes I don't like thinking about
it and we're talking about I don't like
thinking about everyone thinking about
gets it makes me really sad dude I used
to stay up at night and think about this
[ __ ] when I was a kid what is it you
just stop living wow don't even want to
talk about it dude I used to be up at
night I used to run into Dad mom's room
ask him about it they get pissed off
tell me to go back to sleep had tires
look but there's no there's nothing
after you die the lights are just out
we don't talk about it you were talking
about it hopefully there's a Jesus
Christ
hopefully there's somebody back there
wow if it's Nicholas Cage
really hope that there's something after
we die wow lost your [ __ ] mind dude
uh yeah who knows man all I do all I
know is I started talking about being
religious on my podcast how I wish I was
religious and like so many people wrote
me about Jesus Christ and it was four
paragraphs of course they did dude
nobody just talks about Jesus a little
bit you either talk about Jesus not at
all or it's just yeah
it's unbelievable yeah it's because
Jesus to a lot of these people a lot of
people were born and raised with Jesus
in their life but a lot of people that
write messages like that found Jesus yup
dude and they can't help but they got
all the information and they can't wait
to S to show the information they can't
wait to just unblock that [ __ ] verbal
damn of just like
foreign
[Music]
they do yeah I like Jesus Jesus people
say Jesus you know when you go to church
and they're like and Jesus said and
you're like dude you don't need to be
like this about that Jesus Christ yeah
like there's some kind of robot
Jesus Christ what's up bro you need a
coffee
I'm tired no [ __ ] you all right cool I
was [ __ ] popping at the beginning of
this episode what are you talking about
okay you were popping I got worried
about you hitting your head I was scared
I know but it's okay and I'm fine are
you sure yeah honestly I'm telling you
right now dude
it was the kind of thing where it didn't
even hurt at all I was worried about you
yep but it's all good so should we go
into let's get into a thing uh and we'll
talk uh and we'll talk to these people
uh about these people in the videos
Nicolas Cage Nicholas Cage all right
let's do it
Matt and Chris yeah oh my fly merch
today
um I'm gonna try to make this fast I
live up in Canada I've been a server for
four years I've worked in lots of
different places I've done fine dining
sports bars I bartended at a bowling
alley
um my question is how do you deal
with workplace toxicity and I feel like
everywhere I've worked in the restaurant
industry there's always like clicks
there's always drama
and I really honestly I just enjoy what
I do like I love meeting new people and
I like learning new things
um and I have a lot of fun just
getting to interact with people every
day and it doesn't feel like a business
transaction for me like I've genuinely
uh I'm feeling fulfilled of my job but
everywhere I've gone I've always had
like debilitating issues with like
management or staff or like
like there's always just been something
is it the industry do I need to leave
the industry because
that's just the way it goes
or do I need to like
start you know like
because I've tried to stand up for what
I think is right in the way that like
a restaurant should function and it just
like it always
it always has backlash and it always
um isn't the result that I want
do I need to you know just keep pushing
for what I believe
or do I spin move out of the restaurant
industry interesting um
yeah I don't know I feel like uh first
of all I don't think it's just the
restaurant industry I think that what
you're describing clicks and hostility
and toxicity and like group think and
sort of nobody wanted to change that's
just what life is yeah that's talk yeah
that's not your workplaces if you're
going to use toxic like that then it's
just [ __ ] that's work work is toxic
work you should that's how it goes I
wish we were just lounging around not
making and not trying to [ __ ] not
having to go to work you know I mean you
know and you know you love what you're
doing that's great it's weird though you
have a great attitude and I I I would
think like if you work for me or with me
or if I worked for you I would be like
open to what you have to say so it's
kind of odd that you know
people are I don't know what do you
think like I think just show up to work
enjoy the customers tune out the drama
at work and don't uh don't go this is
the only thing I would say in terms of
like maybe be careful of but like don't
go into a workplace and at any point
within the first six months be like you
know how we should do it we should do
that like this like right get your
bearings find where you fit in every in
the place in your place at work and that
either the hierarchy or the click
whatever and then sort of develop a
rapport understand where you are
understand where everyone else is and
then sort of try to maybe steer the ship
in this direction or that direction it
would be great if we didn't realize
because she seemed so sweet that she's
the person that goes in first day of
work just like this needs to change this
needs to change you're a [ __ ] and
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] she did say
something about
trying to have her input no I know it's
something like that I know but I'm
saying I don't know she seems too sweet
for that maybe yeah but maybe she's
making a video for us she knows what
she's really like yeah she didn't air
anybody's business out though I feel
like uh I feel like you uh yeah it's
just
here's the other thing too you can
reframe reframe your mind like if you're
going to work looking to build
relationships and looking for lifelong
friends and to be a part of a click or
this and that then you're just gonna set
yourself up for filler yeah came out
with a good one but the thing is it's
work and that's what it is reframe your
brain look at it as work you can enjoy
what you do but at the end of the day
it's work and it has Texas said today
and I said hey
I can't believe it took you that long to
do that I tried so hard not to do it but
it's just like oh I got what'd you leave
it because I wanted to and I feel like
if you want to make friends and be a
part of my click my click my click my
click my click broke just [ __ ] broke
this is a a musical this podcast okay I
I mean I know I tried to steer it that
way early on worried about the toxicity
in our city and I said hey oh
saw that guy wants that [ __ ] arrow on
and I was like hey what's that big fan
he goes oh hey and then so I'm again and
kind of went like hey and he didn't
didn't even look at me so I don't know
but I feel like uh yeah you you've got
urged turkey yeah unbelievable dude
unbelievable yeah uh best line of all
time why'd you leave it there because I
wanted to that's unbelievable Dude Love
how it's defined what is it why'd you
leave it he's about that because I
wanted to and defiant and about nothing
but serial seriously also an insight to
how he is personally and I love it dude
but yeah if you're going to do a job
that's what it is if you whether you're
serving fine dining whether you're
serving at a bowling alley or whether
you [ __ ] you know serving dance moves
whatever your serving Dude Looks doesn't
matter what your server you could be
serving
yeah but you need to go in with a
different mindset these people are not
working here because it's fulfilling
them these people are working there
because they want that dollar dollar
bill and it's different so already
you're in a different mode than they are
yeah you seem like a sweet person I'm
gonna go with that so these people are
different modes you've got your friends
because you made them as friends
don't look to work for your personal
life like they say don't mix business
was a pleasure well they say that if the
Russian I meant with pleasure not this
pleasure
uh yeah and he figured it out and he's
good dude fairly well put yeah very well
put you meant to say fairly uh yeah dude
so I think that that's really where the
buck stops there
um because I don't know I have friends
with I have work friends you know
comedian friends but my real dogs you
know what my real [ __ ] the
[ __ ] who ride or die very few
Comedians and more non-comedians right
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah I think so yeah
yeah a little bit more
or what friends that are non-comedians
yeah because those are the real
[ __ ] that know the real you you
don't just see them in the halls of the
workplace I you know yeah no yeah for
sure yeah yeah so anyway but but yeah
just don't you know don't be surprised
just be in that mindset in that mode I
feel like anyway we figured it out great
okay okay next next advice Chris been a
big fan of yours since I was 100 years
old I saw you here in Connecticut in
2018. Matt my dad's a big fan of you
from this his dad's filming it my
favorite Delia is Bill whenever you guys
call him his laugh just gets me he's
great a little bit about myself I'm 20
years old I'm a chemical engineering
student here at UConn wow I'm two jobs I
go to the gym five days a week I don't
party I'm very dialed in and happy with
what I'm doing
my question comes in regards to a
girlfriend I have never had feelings
really reciprocated with a female that
type of movie you know
thing how the you know romantic
relationships are portrayed I've never
really had anything like that at all uh
and every time I've gotten close I just
continuously get hurt to the point where
now I'm 20 years old and I live like a
divorced guy kind of angry at women
because they keep hurting me and it's
it's more how I go about it myself but
you know
my life is good I'm happy I have friends
you know it's just great but I also know
I am lacking in a major department of
affection because I block out Chris I
know you've talked about this a lot I
block out a lot of my emotions and I
just go I'm just gonna stay you know
whatever so no one can hurt me
I'll be in school for a while going to
grad school gonna be here for a while so
you know there's ample opportunity to
meet a female so I'm not too worried but
I want I want to know what you guys
think about getting around that mindset
of I'm staying away from girls because
they're just going to keep hurting new
noise oh yeah love you guys okay love
you too first thing just up front don't
get mad at women
don't get mad at women in general you
haven't met all of the women in fact
you've met a very very low amount of
them so you don't go get three mad at
them just because you're had a crush on
three of them and they didn't
reciprocate right right okay you don't
like deserve their affection in return
yeah that's the [ __ ] tough love part
now right that's over with no more tough
love just regular love now okay okay uh
like you said you're [ __ ] 20.
so you're young as hell and if you want
to know what relationships are like even
though you if you haven't been in one
here's a place to not look for an
example of how they should be movies
people seen too many movies absolutely
no relationship has ever been like any
relationship in at least a Hollywood
movie there's just no [ __ ] way well
movies end dude movies end on a [ __ ]
high note yes life ain't life's not a
high note life's full of notes and
they're up and they're down and they're
down and they're down and they're up and
they're down and [ __ ] gets [ __ ] up
dude Jerry Maguire ended nice you know
what that's why the graduate is so
[ __ ] good yeah because they they go a
little bit longer than the end and then
you see their smiles fade and then
they're just like oh now we gotta live
our life actually like there's no such
thing as a happy ending uh that's much
more honest yeah than a [ __ ] Cameron
Crow movie for sure
um
but all all that being said that's just
like a foundational thing just
be
you're because you're so young and you
have a you're in this like um
petri dish of call like college life
yeah you're gonna meet so many women
just by the fact that you're standing
there right they're around they're
around and this is not a that's unique
to college and you know grad school
whatever same thing
you will meet more women and you will
have a variety of experiences with them
some good some bad
there's no reason to generalize about
all of them you're going to meet one and
I know you're probably sick of hearing
this but dude you are 20. yeah no I know
we're not so good one that actually that
you actually like that actually likes
you back and then you're gonna be like
oh my God remember how bitter I was yeah
and what you're feeling now is not even
going to make sense to you I had a chip
on my lease a little bit like give up
the grip a little bit it'll go it'll
pass it'll go it'll get better I have I
had a chip on my shoulder when I was
younger about about women you know and
like and and it went away but it it but
the you know it can go away and and you
know because it's hard to grow up and
you want you know when you're figuring
out your sexuality and you like you know
you you like women and they're not
liking you or whatever it is I mean not
every woman's gonna like you
um but yeah dude you're you're the good
thing is is that you're very self-aware
you're you seem like you've got a good
head on your shoulder on your shoulders
and it's okay to live right now for the
way you want to with the way you're for
your work and your you know you should
be focused on school and work and [ __ ]
like that all that other [ __ ] will come
but just be open to it dude don't just
shut him out and say you know the second
you adopt this yeah oh I don't like
women or I don't like this you're
already half of that is you just saying
it if you just stop saying that and then
actively think like okay maybe I'm wrong
about it dude you're gonna find someone
the next day it's also not true and you
know that's not you know that's not
right you know because you can tell you
no that's not right
um
dude you know it's wrong to hate a
certain group of people yeah like first
and I know he kind of just he was just
speaking and not everything he said was
like we shouldn't [ __ ] hold him to
the
um but yeah dude uh you got this and
then also uh you know he said he's what
a chemical engineer yeah that's crazy
yeah so yeah focus on your work because
we need people like you to focus on your
work and don't get lost and you could be
calling with all sorts of women problems
and then what happens is uh all your
your chemical engineering gets [ __ ] up
and then people die and chemical spills
and [ __ ] yep whoops but baby but baby I
didn't mean to oh no the chemical spills
yep right gotta be careful and then what
does it deal with toxicity
literally okay yeah literally toxicity
in our city yeah yeah so that could be
the episode named toxicity yeah I think
it's gonna be okay or just toxicity okay
but uh yeah I feel I feel you bro but
just get on get it come on bro you're so
regimented in the rest of your life
chill with the women yeah dude don't put
the [ __ ] kibosh on that [ __ ] don't
really do anything just change your
attitude how about this I love all women
I can't wait to meet the [ __ ] one
that I'm going to spend the rest of my
life or whatever yeah with you know like
just pick
ah yeah what's that I don't know oh just
what he's doing you know cool sounds
good yeah I'm for that yeah this was him
walking though oh yeah well I knew that
yeah but I didn't know what the tick oh
yeah was it was the shift of perspective
got it everything's Rosy and now he's
walking down the street like yeah okay
all right cool then do your [ __ ]
I got a bone to pick with you because I
can't stop saying oops wow and life rips
and and things that you guys say and now
all my friends and family yeah they
don't like that I'm so annoyed with you
that's okay dude what advice would you
give
on not repeating things like I have
revert they get stuck in your teacher he
just [ __ ] went just got back to his
life dude it didn't end the video dude
you didn't even give a [ __ ] did it kept
going it's still on this is Ed TV right
um yeah uh yeah dude take a chicken
stuck in your head it gets stuck in my
head all the time but here's the good
thing I'll create a thing and then
people will start doing it and then I
stop doing it because everyone starts
doing it okay so be your own Creator but
what I would suggest too is make
everyone in your life
also talk like that yeah I know way
better dude everyone talks the way we
create it because we created it and we
won't back down dude no we will not back
down there will be no backing down yeah
remember the first time we said to drunk
I remember the first time I said to
drunk no yep it was with uh that um
camera operator we used to work with I
don't want to say his name but Mike okay
well we don't have to say his phone last
night he was drunk and uh yeah no not
not Alba though no I know yeah yeah yeah
and uh and he was drunk and I forget we
were probably somewhere up in Sacramento
or some [ __ ] doing that thing oh oh yeah
and he was drunk and and we just I just
said drunk and we were already doing
this stuff and then you laughed so hard
because I texted it ask apostrophe drunk
for the first time
um
yeah Milestone what a milestone it was a
milestone dude yeah we who knew dude I
love when you create [ __ ] and you don't
know it's gonna be a thing that's
popping off in your family with your
friends and it's the things everything
though you know what do you mean
technically everything is not planned
that it's gonna pop off no I know well I
know that but but there's so few things
that actually pop off yes and sometimes
you're like oh that's gonna pop off and
it it has no legs right no legs right
yeah but this is deeper issues and the
[ __ ]
um defensivo yeah that [ __ ] that we do
that that who knew that was gonna pop up
yeah yeah um so yeah just roll with it
even harder man alienate your alienate
yourself don't even have family members
that don't do it this is a cult bro okay
super cold no no oh you're giving back
subscribe by the way just make them talk
like you but that's kind of what I mean
by this is a cult I don't actually mean
talk about how the end of the world is
coming but I don't want him to get it
twisted like if they don't get on board
then he separates his own way so he
don't want to be solo like Travis
Bitcoin so basically he's he's failing
if he doesn't get them to yeah keep
being around them and just you're
failing bro be better at it yeah get
better try and [ __ ] get them on board
also dude maybe he's not doing it well
maybe he's not doing it those tubes that
were great that wasn't a great it was he
was forcing it you know an announcer
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then also you
know life rips is obviously you can't
force life riffs because life obviously
just rips but like yeah the just just uh
you know relax into it make it be a part
of you he's into it yeah there's a
difference between hey here's this cool
shirt I'm wearing and hey here's me in
this shirt be more than hey here's me in
this shirt guy yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah don't go out and get it have
it be in you and go with it when it
comes out we've never said more nothing
than what we're saying but you know what
I mean you know what we mean though
um yeah very cool very cool all right
next all right
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
betterhelp is a lifesaver it is honestly
one of the greatest things I've ever
discovered and I'm very happy to be able
to share it on this show with you life
is hard and better hope is extremely
helpful and as the world's largest
therapy service better help has matched
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable
uh just fill out a brief questionnaire
to match with a therapist and if you
don't like that therapist if things
aren't exactly clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
could not be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist better help does it all
for you learn more and save 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
Lifeline that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash lifeline
we the holidays are here the holidays
are here it is the season of giving
people things we are popping our merch
all over the place thank you thanks to
ship station ship station is the bomb as
uh my mom says the most wonderful time
of the year is also the most hectic Time
of the Year everyone puts off shopping
until the last minute I know I do and if
you have an online store you know the
feeling of getting hit with a ton of
orders all at once when you're buried in
orders and emails from stress customers
you will wish you had ship station ship
station turns holidays ship storms into
smooth sailing so you can keep your
customers happy and still find time to
enjoy some eggnog
shipstation Keeps Us prepared for
Lifeline drops and the holiday season
for our merch everybody loves ship
station over 130 000 companies have
grown their e-commerce businesses with
ship station and 98 of companies that
stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life baby for life
this holiday season give yourself the
gift of stress-free holiday shipping use
the promo code Lifeline today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code lifeline
so I'm in a bit of a dilemma
my dilemma is that every person you put
on the show is white trash no I'm
kidding
um I am in a dilemma though uh and yeah
I don't have a therapist because you
know expensive but
I would if I could but that's why I have
you guys anyways
um my issue is that every guy that
genuinely likes me and cares for me
never gets me something it is like
really good for me I [ __ ] like I
don't like freak out in front of them
right but like I like get someone
attracted to them I get the ick and like
I don't know why and I'm like do I have
daddy issues and I'm like no my dad was
pretty good like I don't know why like
I'm not lesbian I'm not asexual it's
just like I don't know what to do about
it like do I go
like I don't know I'm I'm I'm confused
you think you're confused I'm [ __ ]
confused like why why do like women like
I mean a one-woman show a one-woman show
that's the most sunburned person I've
seen without that that's about some
person I've seen that didn't say
anything about their sunburn I thought
she was I thought that was makeup that
she was doing I had no idea is it okay
it has to be if it's [ __ ] November
dude but anyway yeah okay so what's this
question she's asking she's asking she
doesn't she likes guys that don't like
her and and girl and she likes guys that
don't like her and guys that like her
don't she gets the ick what the [ __ ] uh
Chris explain yeah what's going on I
don't get either don't replay it once a
guy starts to like her she gets turned
off oh dude
you got to go to therapy once a day you
got once a day you gotta go to therapy
every day that that is the worst
possible thing that's so weird man you
gotta go to I don't want to say it's
weird but it's [ __ ] weird dude hey
dude he got problems and it's fine but
figure it out right it has to it very
clearly has to do with how you feel
about you yeah dude because if if every
time a guy starts to like you you're
like like yo this guy sucks then like
you clearly have to think about how you
think about you you've gotta you've got
an insecurity issue about yourself you
got to realize deep down and I mean deep
down like in your heart deep deep down
in your tummy deep all right under your
[ __ ] you got to realize that you're
this [ __ ] and if you do then them liking
you isn't gonna dry y'all up right it's
not gonna dry you all up and you're
gonna be like oh [ __ ] my towel budget
has skyrocketed
okay yeah you know what I'm saying I
know what you're saying no bro I don't
think that that's really right actually
it's not accurate I think it's not an
accurate portrayal of her percentage
that the towel budget will go up
that's absolutely ridiculous that's
ridiculous dude that's ridiculous you're
basically proposing that she's gonna
make herself wet
because people are gonna like her and
then she's gonna be able to do the
horizontal Mambo more towel budget is
going to have to go up because she's
going to always have dirty Towers
because she's now okay you know I don't
mean to be gross but it's like well
you're being gross yeah so it's like
deep deep love for yourself you have to
have deep love for you don't go
overboard some people just need to like
themselves a little bit more you don't
have to go around this world having a
deep immense love for yourself I think
you do you don't I don't have that for
myself you just need then there you go I
know but I'm insecure and I wish no but
okay you need a healthy dose of
everything everything in moderation but
you can't be so down on yourself that
anytime someone else likes you you're
like ew this person's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh-huh right that's not good you gotta
give yourself a little bit of love
see what happens do you think I'm going
overboard and you've got to reel it back
in a little bit for yes okay yes you yes
uh yeah dude I mean I think that uh
basically you just gotta work on loving
yourself a little bit more and then once
a guy likes you you know maybe he
[ __ ]
maybe it doesn't I don't know it is kind
of weird though it's like that whole
thing I can't remember what comedian
says it but I don't want to be a member
of of any club that would have me yeah
that's Groucho Marx is it yeah
um and it's just like uh
yeah it's just it's a tough thing right
because it because it's that exclusivity
that oh you don't like me well what the
what the hell yeah I mean it would make
more sense if you were younger we've got
to get past that [ __ ] though it's like a
younger person like I could see being
like oh well you like me now it's time
to move on I gotta get somebody else to
like me right but like you don't look
that no offense you don't look you don't
look like a teenager yeah yeah
um work on loving yourself and as you
work on loving yourself every day put a
little cash aside right every day and
then once you truly love yourself you'll
be able to go buy the towels that you
need wow okay but another thing I would
say why is she saying everybody in the
show's [ __ ] white trash that was the
joke I think I didn't mean that I don't
I don't I think that was a joke yeah I
don't feel like that that's not even
true first of all no I don't think so at
all not even close well what's it say go
up I mean the eyebrows on this chick
right here well we stop liking guys
a guy the second he returned oh yeah go
go on the internet for this answer yeah
the worst boys like a girl likes a boy
boy let's go back never mind girl
doesn't like boy anymore who gives
having a crush on someone is almost like
a drug it makes you Giddy and nutty warm
and fuzzy nervous and eager it almost
it's almost an addictive feeling yeah I
agree with the emotional highs and
excitement we feel just a simple
interaction acting is feel for the rest
of our day yeah sure yeah I get it
sometimes it's about the thrill of the
chase uh yeah I understand that why they
have been Benedict Cumberbatch you know
go down what's he saying in that the
thrill of the chase the blood pumping
through your veins is just the two of us
against the rest of the world that's
what he said in some stupid movie
um you want you always want what you
can't have yeah but that's [ __ ]
supply and demand dude
but that's so immature like supply and
demand right just yeah and this that
could be a title too supplying the man
Supply and the man okay but honestly
get over it get over whatever's stopping
you you're an adult be an adult [ __ ]
we hate saying get over it because it's
not so easy but be an adult in the adult
[ __ ] world yeah she dissed our Audi
our audience I don't I don't like it I
mean it was let's just assume it was a
joke because it's just so not true it
wasn't even what's the joke then that
will you have white trash in her or
orange is white trash what's the joke
that's not a joke you don't make that
joke up out of thin air that's nothing
yeah so you're like saying you're saying
it's literally the same thing as saying
like how come everybody who calls in is
a donkey yes
okay yes
I mean we've definitely had one or two
so that's not an insult white trash is a
derogatory term oh get it get it
okay maybe she's
maybe she's white trash that's what I'm
saying that's why that [ __ ] sunburn
right yeah true and then she did have
some wood paneling in the background I
think she's [ __ ] I hate this I hate
the name call but you know
Park hole in the kettle we could have
been like that but we didn't do it right
I said something like that one you did
yeah okay cool all right I don't listen
all right cool all right
here we go oh oh wow it's an hourglass
his head is an hourglass wow a peanut
what a person Matt so my question to you
guys is this guy would defend I've been
working in this retail phone retail
store for a year and four months and I'm
on trade school doing HVAC oh nice but I
also find another good paint job
position
but you know I'm kind of loyal to my job
and I don't know if I should quit I
could definitely get significantly fit
significantly more pay in my in the
other job but I'm just very doubtful I
don't know what to do how do you think I
should take this to my boss and how do
you think I should tell them uh that I'm
leaving for a better position I
appreciate you guys for your time and
thank you it's never been more there's
never been someone there's never been
someone that is more equally percentage
every single race that's ever been that
guy's a good bomb dude yeah he's a great
oh dude that guy you're right he's the
most loyal person in the world and you
can tell just by his head defend you to
the death yeah he would do it and he
would never leave you dude he had his
same girlfriend from when he first met
the girl right right and marry her has
kids would defend their honors so much
unbelievable and always shows to work in
a [ __ ] black tank top dude and eat
dinner with a black tank top on right
right right when you play the beginning
of that he loves taco Tuesdays because I
want to hear what he says the very
beginning yeah
Taco Tuesday what up Chris and Matt so
my question to you guys is I've been
working in this retail phone retail
store I'd be working for a year and four
months and I'm on trade school doing
HVAC but I also find another good paint
job position
but you know I'm kind of loyal to my job
okay what is HVAC yeah
yeah okay and what we're gonna say
I was gonna say I think he's just trying
to um find uh this is the job he's
working until he's done with hvs yes
but then so in the interim like he found
a better job for just the interim part
oh
so trade schools he's not stopping trade
school no matter what sounds like okay
don't stop trade school you're gonna
make a [ __ ] good living doing that
[ __ ] HVAC is
highly in demand [ __ ] people
need that [ __ ] yeah uh okay so I found
out what it was but yeah yeah
um
dude if you got a better paying job in
the interim talk to your boss and just
be like hey yeah I love it here and I
love you but I need to make money and
this other job is offering me more money
how am I gonna buy [ __ ] black tank
tops for taco Tuesday yeah yeah no but
seriously though like you are clearly a
good guy your boss understands that you
are a good guy because he knows you
already
he'll understand dude he would do the
same thing yeah you can't stay at a
phone company just out of loyalty you're
loyal to a fault dude you're loyalty
like you're loyal to Nokia you know like
just [ __ ] move on dude they don't
they don't care what I do they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah you know ever since
snake you know it's like dude he's
[ __ ] you know go to your boss and be
like look boss you know I'm loyal to my
soil but still man like you know you
just want to say loyalty yeah I did I
did my son is the stupidest thing in the
world and people say it people say it
mean it you know I'm a little to my soil
dog yeah yeah that's not good to say no
it's not good to say at all dude yeah
but people who say it all the time and
then they do it like this hey man
um hey Doug I'm loyal to my soil
oh my God more hey dog I'm loaded to my
soil I keep waiting for you to forget
about this
[Applause]
wow
wrong
uh yeah dude
yeah all right I don't know man you're
doing good though you're [ __ ] you're
gonna be the [ __ ] dude that guy with no
job [ __ ] awesome if he uh put for
real war like um what do they call it
mascara like the purple up no that's not
mascara is it but it's like um I blush
eyeshadow eye shadow dude I should wear
eye shadow I'm telling you check your
[ __ ] life because it got real nice
eyelids and [ __ ] they were always at
half mast the guy looks high but he's
never smoked weed you know because he's
about those soil no yeah he he doesn't
do drugs um he should do both jobs
both what jobs yeah take the job and
then just reduce his hour to the phone
please oh
then he might get overworked with the
trade school though um yeah three things
you don't want to burn out he's not
Jimmy if you're Jamaican you can do that
but if you're well he's a little bit
equal race expectation not Jamaican the
guys that stack jobs like that no it's
not I thought it's Jamaican no no the
haitian's down in Florida really got
like eight jobs okay Haitians
okay fine you make me out to be a racist
but no no
that's you making you out to be racist
no uh all right so what else we got
hi Matt and Chris my name is Ollie this
one I'll probably tell from my accent
I'm from Australia I don't know but I'm
actually gonna be you look like that
though and everybody looks like that in
the US for about a year
um I leave in a couple weeks obviously
it's gonna be a bit of a cultural shock
for me
um rocking up from another country and
everything
um so I was wondering if you guys had
any tips or advice for me on how to kind
of fit into your culture a little bit
better I know you guys do stuff like
tipping and driving on the wrong side of
the road
um things like that which we don't
really do here
um so yeah it's just funny if you had
any advice for me on how I can kind of
fit into your culture and little things
I can expect when I get there
anyway any advice would be super handy
um so yeah have a good one and uh life
rips yeah oh yeah dude you're gonna do
great you're an Australian guy that
looks like that American and is going to
love you yeah do it that's the end I
wanted to know anything about about
American culture you're gonna kill the
guy's acting like he's in Japan it's
[ __ ] Australia you know no I get I
get where he's come from but he doesn't
realize
what he's bringing to the table go back
one you know yeah Americans American
women love us like the accent
um
yeah no he'll be fine with that
um
you look good you look good yeah I feel
like he could probably uh uh he's fine
he'll be fine 100 all right I understand
you know yeah you tip in Australia too
don't you oh no you don't do you tip in
Australia I don't know if you dependent
anywhere besides here do you tip
initiative in Australia dude um he said
he's gonna be here for a year
one year yeah four a year one year or in
a year one year guy's gonna be [ __ ]
loaded up man yeah guy's gonna be loaded
up man he's gonna just gonna love that
dude yeah oh the guy can't wait
the guy can't wait yeah oh uh I went to
Australia once bath bathe daily like
make sure you're clean yeah not to
profile Australians but like no
Americans are clean freaks yeah more
Americans are clear I I I take a shower
every single day uh people always think
I don't I take a shower every day and
your voice smells fantastic I don't know
they think our hair looks greasy but
that has nothing to do with how often
you should they just say [ __ ] like we
look like greasy Birds but dude I'll
tell you right now I shower every day
and your boy smells [ __ ] fantastic
I shower every day yeah I understand but
I'm yeah good
that's fine I mean I don't think you
need to shower every day but I I do I
guess I don't every day yeah and I'll
miss a day every once I don't miss a day
yeah you don't yeah and I smell
fantastic and you you would admit that
yeah you've never smelled not good yeah
so there you go haters everyone thinks
that I I look like I smell bad and I
don't shower who thinks that I don't
know I'm just maybe I don't know I'm
just saying you smell bad no okay well
you smell good dude I think if people
looked at me and you think does that you
think that guy smells bad they might be
like yeah he might smell bad no I don't
I mean maybe because I know you so well
but I can't really get out of the
mindset but you're you're like a clean
freak look at all these things cultural
gift giving gifts are usually given on
special occasions imagine googliness and
try to find out like people tend to open
give this is so Asian to look up for
America but what is it it's just it's
rude to ask directly how much a gift
costs I mean you know what are they oh
this is really nice how much was this
thanks a lot for this chocolate how much
was it would it take you back
every gift you know it is insulting to
it's a giveaway or re-gift or throw away
oh thanks so much for this oh no guy
would love it how much was it I'll tell
him tell me yeah get over here uh look
at this re-gift or throw away the gift
don't do this if you do so do not make
this gift known to the do not make this
known to The Gift Giver wow so they're
saying if you're gonna be shitty just
don't tell anybody about it we know you
know yeah yeah yeah is it rude to eat
look at this is it Rudy with your mouth
open open lick your plate lick your
plate what are you a dog all right so
thank you for meeting with me really
good steak
was great oh you're paying for it how
much was it all
can't wait to throw this up in my
friend's mouth
disgusting hit three all in one asking
how much it is licking the plate and
[ __ ] re-gifting yeah uh uh wow all
right all right you're gonna do fine it
doesn't matter what the cultural mores
are here you look like that and sound
like that but that's hilarious to ask as
an Australian
I get it though it's not that crazy okay
is that weird I went to Australia and I
just pretty much winged it and I think I
was pretty polite and good oh you're on
the most wanted list in Australia though
you didn't know that yeah you know why I
robbed six Banks yeah yep that'll do it
Sydney Australia rub three Banks two in
Melbourne and then one in Adelaide
giving yourself up
well this yeah there's no extraditional
yeah there is definitely between
Australia let's go next
I mean oh
oh
Chris no way I've been a long time fan
love the new show David was wondering if
you got some advice for me uh finding
more alone time with your significant
other when uh you may have a baby you
may get a new puppy you know something
like that and your schedule's a little
bit busier than it used to be uh my
girlfriend and I we just got a puppy
things are always great It's just
sometimes we find each other a little
bit more tired uh just wondering what
you guys thought give me some advice
thanks guys that was a cool video dude
every time we talk about something the
beginning of the thing it shows up later
on the episode he's doing the cigarettes
thing and you were talking about
advertising cigarettes in a place what
about cigarettes then we're talking
about advertising cigarettes in place
and you couldn't do it and then he's
[ __ ] stacking cigarettes oh oh this
is really weird man didn't even notice
um yeah dude uh
okay okay I feel differently about this
than I think a lot of people so why
don't you go ahead uh and then I got
something to this I could go so look
I have a wife and a son four dogs
I
I maybe I'm codependent I don't ever
want a loan time
I I don't want that
I love being at home
and I you know look I do go on the road
but I bring them a lot I go on the road
and I guess I I guess I I don't I don't
know like you have a job you work nine
to this is what I don't get you have a
job you work down at five say and I
don't know if you do or not but like
generally you work nine to five you are
away from your family
I guess that's technically not alone
time but when you get home don't you
want to just be with your family
what is alone time to you first of all
you he means quality time with his
partner I thought he said he wants more
alone time no did he not say that
he meant with his partner oh all right
well that's different that's different
okay yeah yeah yeah uh quality time with
the partner when you have things like a
baby and a puppy that does oh he met
alone time with his significant other
okay gotcha yeah I mean I don't know if
people do date night once a week
yeah I mean I think
I think typically specifically men are
very resistant to like the committed day
of the week or time of the day that you
do this thing men are very like
knee-jerk they have a knee-jerk
preference for spontaneity but there
really is something to be said for the
thing that's on the calendar that you do
all the time it's like maintenance dude
it's like this is the this is the uh
time you have therapy every week this is
the time you have just YouTube time
every week it's like you gotta as life
gets longer and we get older like more
and more [ __ ] fills our life and you
gotta schedule the [ __ ] that's important
and that's a good way to [ __ ] make
sure you commit the time and you know
when it's on the calendar you know he
studies sometimes he's just too tired
it's like well then rest up for that
[ __ ] make sure you're not tired at that
time you know my my I had a therapist
that used to say this is a while ago but
you used to say like dude you you take
your car to the shop you got to take
your relationship there too you know
like it needs maintenance basically what
you were saying yeah
um yeah dude
um I I think men view quality time as
being together and women view quality of
time as doing something you know yeah
with the person yeah so I bro I I don't
you know but but this guy seems like
he's coming from more of the female
perspective and he boy he's just willing
he's whatever he's done for whatever got
it as long as it's I say quality time
yeah I don't know sometimes you know
you're in a relationship where it's like
but we want more quality time it's like
what the [ __ ] do they used to be with
this with this girl that was like uh
but we never talk and I'm like oh we've
been doing is talking and I don't she's
like yeah but we just talk about
[ __ ] and I'm like oh so she meant
about things about substance deep [ __ ]
yeah but we do what we say I've been
with you for two years what do you want
me to I don't understand I never
understood it I still don't understand
it no you don't talk about deep [ __ ] you
don't so she was right you should
apologize to her
right now that's my One X I don't talk
to anymore okay well I think that it's
high time to talk to her and to
apologize to her hey sorry I never
talked about deep [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] was that yeah um yeah yeah
you don't talk about deep [ __ ] though
I'd rather talk about pants or something
I know that but you should mix in deep
[ __ ] goes what did she want what did she
mean what who
my ex you don't talk about [ __ ] of
substance that matters Big Ideas big
things that matter in life the future
the [ __ ] gotta see my new act bro I'm
crushing see what I'm saying oh that's
all you want to talk about whatever that
and like people who have seen you on
stage and liked you whatever that's like
you'll be like oh costus Mandalore I
love that guy he's a fan of mine you
know what I mean who's cost us Mandalore
the the sexy Greek guy uh that was in a
bunch of [ __ ] in the 90s
you would be like oh I love that guy I
think it might be like why and you'd be
like oh I saw him at a show
a Saw movie and also he was in so much
something I literally just watched
called blowback with uh
um uh uh that UFC fighter uh [ __ ] what's
his name oh he's in a bunch of this song
he was sexy dude
is he still sexy uh no no I mean he's
you know he's like more of a uh a
non-sexy guy now
like a character actor kind of guy yeah
oh looks look at his IG he's just look
at him with the dog yeah
yeah so he's there's Costas mandal or
that there he is being a [ __ ] pimp
wow where is he right there yeah how
about we click on one well that's just
him because that's better yeah right
there he keeps skipping it there we go
there he is that's him no that's a
different person unless that's from a
while ago no
uh oh wow what's that dude I'm gonna
show it I mean his [ __ ] legs are
spread so wide dude yeah Costas is back
it says how much is he so ridiculous for
ridiculously famous in Brazil you know
in Greece oh he's Greece Greece he's
he's Greek
okay well anyway uh
no I I talk about elevated things a lot
okay
yep kind of getting such a big argument
menu after the show
um yeah so okay well all right all right
do we want to do one last one or the one
last one hey what's going on guys Conor
coming to you from Shanghai China whoa
whoa and I have a question for you guys
about patience
um
so I'm under lockdown along with
everyone else in the city 25 million
people as I can believe it so what's
going on in China with the outbreak here
zero zero covet policy is what's going
on could be from a while ago too oh
right it could be still going on you see
that [ __ ] no I know there's a new thing
going on oh right yeah no it's a while
it could have been a while ago yeah yeah
who knows when they have an outbreak
they shut things down Jesus yes exactly
yeah shut it down dude it's it's not
even that bad
China China doesn't want it dude you
cough a little bit China doesn't want it
okay let's do it and um
it's a it's a difficult situation for a
lot of people because we don't know when
lockdown is going to end
um it's similar to solitary confinement
where we are confined to our Apartments
um we can't see anyone else we can't go
outside we can't go for a walk what
um and uh originally it was supposed to
last five days and it's been 40 so far
oh probably closer to 50 when you guys
see this video so the question is
how to deal with God this situation that
we are in and how to be positive and be
patient
um when you know you can't control it
and you and you don't know when it's
going to end
um which I think a lot of us
um foreigners and Chinese people
included are are struggling with uh to
some degree yeah
um I love it here I love being in China
and uh so you know doing a spin move as
Chris would say and uh leaving China is
not going to be an option for
for uh your advice to us
um let me know what you guys think and
uh as always life rips even when it
doesn't that's right appreciate it bro I
think I get those [ __ ] prison
workouts in those [ __ ] burpees and
jumping around and just [ __ ] get
shredded there's no excuse not to be
shredded at the end of the day
I mean not the end of the day but then
that's crazy this obviously an old video
but man I mean dude you got to be
shredded you got to be jacked pick up a
talent get good at those [ __ ] uh you
know where you try to [ __ ] swing the
ball up into the cup you know I mean how
do you eat by the way how do you get I
was just gonna say how does that work
gotta be able to go to the grocery store
I guess or something I don't know who
knows government workers just come in
like sealed up suits and they're just
like your dinner so God bro what a
nightmare oh
I think honestly that's that [ __ ]
sucks man what do you do and what's even
the advice video games uh workouts
um
you know read I have a good one I have a
good one
become an expert in something you've
always been interested in becoming not
don't become good at it don't become
pretty knowledgeable about something
become a [ __ ] expert like whether
it's like a historical thing you wanted
to know about some kind of uh science
thing you wanted to know about whatever
it is just like a certain animal
wildlife
a [ __ ] ex become an expert at that
and you can because you have access to
the internet of nothing else yeah do
they have the access to Internet in
China oh yeah it's there I'm kidding
it's their internet but it's it's still
internet I know right you know I mean
they get the limited internet but yeah
yeah but it's pretty it's pretty you
know watch my specials that would be
great
um
yeah over and over again Watch Chris's
specials yeah dude oh man that's a rough
one dude I'm sorry
sorry that that happened what else even
is there to say this is [ __ ] brutal
yeah 50 days oh I've not even [ __ ]
of not even seeing people and no human
touch my gosh he said he sounds like he
lives with someone though right if he
lives with someone thank god dude that's
great but also if he doesn't though
scary to live with someone also you
definitely have to start singing r b
because look at your face right I mean
dude the guy shows beards it looks like
you strap it off 100 this how he gets
ready to go out
it's the beer yeah the guy's just
[ __ ]
oh yeah
oh yeah dude 100 percent
um all right well uh yeah that's the
show my friends go to go to
chrysalia.com
that's the show my friends and lovers
and children of the world
okay okay
uh oh you know go to go to chrissy.com
go to chrissy.com get your tickets right
you could go to mattdelia.com to get the
sessions with Matt and then you could go
to watch lifeline.com if you have a uh
if you want to submit a video and then
get your merch at lifelinemerch.com you
can also get this at crystalleergut.com
thank you very much order it order it up
for friends and family holiday we hey
hello hello hello hello
[Music]